every shot has to get if you have one
wild shot Oh like I was embedded this
pristine arrow in the door thank you
everyone
use your determine right here in obscura
1000 the rules you want to try to get a
bull's-eye with each one of your shots
and the further away from the bullseye
you are the more points you get the goal
of the game is to get the fewest number
of points possible
okay okay wait so a goal you're a planet
like this planet the further you are
away from the bullseye the more points
you get the more points you get the more
likely you lose okay so are you doing in
my inches without you joke one one point
so easy yeah you should have said that
let's set this up so it's actually like
presented today marks the first annual
order Digital archery tournament we are
going to shoot six arrows three rounds
to me this will decide the order that we
go in I got a 3-1 Jay daddy's gone we
know or 13 18 and 12 / let's do this
right and dead center we go guys
from the black dot they're 13 five six
five next one is three birdies to curl
we have no context whether that is good
or bad
here we go round one is the warm-up and
five is all before but uh hopefully
things go well yes we get Peter shut
good stalling around I don't understand
how I got thirty ready for round two
yeah this is a nice shirt so shiny and
blingy
gotta get a zero how Michael has
embedded this pristine arrow in the door
oh good pliers I've been pulling this
hoping I just slam the door for now a
professional Archer and a amateur award
designer
next round three you know what guys
no I am gonna leave over my last round
what I did last night that isn't it hero
though yeah feels like magic magic magic
stuff magic powder on my face mess it up
now red horrible or lower and take your
time
or a fire
oh yeah oh my god on your 15 say uh 13
in last place Carmichael with a hundred
and thirteen points thanks for watching
skating in second-to-last is Jake with
76 points top in fourth place is red
layer with 74 points third place is
Daniel D with 70 then you'll be and
second place Sam goth given 55 points
nice now and the new winner
this year's archery tournament is Nico
with 43 points that's gonna have time
show set up this is a fleet turns over
usual halftime shot for the term it's
over oh I'll do better in the winter
sword fights twist it up gotta use the
Wazza just move this out of the way
first
yes I like it I did no but toesies oh if
something went through the box
got it